menés par un autochtone 6 et mélissa
marion dupuis cette semaine on a reçu
une question du public qu'on va les
écouter
j'aimerais bien ça allez vous rencontrer
et puis allez dans le grand nom mais
c'était difficile d'aller dans le grand
nord moi je te suis une personne qui
voyage quand même beaucoup
puis à chaque fois je regarde les prix
des billets d'avion c'est vraiment
inaccessible
si un jour c'est plus accessible de
j'aimerais bien ça les voir merci
beaucoup pour la question c'est un enjeu
qui ne concerne pas uniquement les pour
les communautés québécoises mais aussi
les communautés des premières nations
une accessibilité aux régions où on
habite
mobiclip rayan nation on est souvent
dans des régions à s'éloigner qui ont
des frais n'ont aucun accès à la route
ou même des fois par la mer alors
communauté donc c'est soit l'avion le
train et c'est certain que l'éloignement
fait que le transport vont être
extrêmement cher extrêmement coûteux on
sait que pourrait dans le grand nord le
billet d'avion que dès fois deux fois
plus cher que pour se rendre à paris ou
à londres
donc c'est certain entre paris et
londres et que jack souvant on va voir
l'attirance pour aller dans les vieux
pays mais un grand obstacle justement à
se rendre dans les communautés et qui
faciliterait justement la multiplication
de transport est en commun comme les
autobus d'être est beaucoup plus
sécuritaire où beaucoup plus accessible
et des billets d'avion moins cher ça
serait que les gens du québec décident
d'aller visiter leur région et on a vu
une augmentation justement du tourisme
comme sur la côte nord ce qui fait que
l'accessibilité s'agrandit et fait
baisser les coûts ensuite c'est de
rentrer dans les communautés mais ça ça
se fait lors de pareilles à des
événements publics ouverts à tous et
vous êtes très à éviter à venir partager
avec nous mais vraiment je pensais
l'accessibilité la première c'est
vraiment le coût des transports et plus
les gens vont s'y intéresser plus les
routes vont devenir sécuritaire grâce
justement à la pression puis au support
des communautés non autochtone plus les
gens vont êtes intéressé à y aller donc
c'est certain que se tourner les yeux
vers l'intérieur de notre territoire
plutôt que 20 d'autres pays
ça peut être la première porte d'entrée
pour aller créer une réconciliation pis
justement des communautés beaucoup plus
serré merci pour la question
j'espère que j'ai pu y répondre et
j'espère vous avez nous en envoyer
d'autres appareils autochtone c'est une
très belle semaine